this video is brought to you on the true
geordie channel by surf shock absolutely
do you know what a vpn is what not a vpn
is a virtual private network do you know
what that means i'll explain let's put
yourself anywhere in the world virtually
privately networkly basically if you
want to be able to watch netflix in
america and i know you do then you can
put yourself digitally in america that
means that you can watch the netflix
over there if you've gone all the way
through the netflix over here
so you're also sitting in a coffee shop
and you think hold on a minute there are
hackers in coffee shops one of these
people might try and be getting to my
data this allows you to put yourself
anywhere else and remain virtually
anonymous online so if you want to make
yourself a little less trackable online
get on surf shark and the best thing
about it is it's so affordable 83 off
three months for free and it gets even
better than this they got a 30 day money
back guarantee so if you're not happy
with it in those first 30 days you can
get your money back and for all of that
all you need is code geordie when you
check out hit the link in the
description go take a look at it no
pressure to buy but you know what if you
do there's 30 days money back guarantee
i'm just saying that's amazing yeah it's
surf shock he just did that
by that's pretty good one take no need
for any more cameras just the one camera
right there and you're about to watch a
great video right here blue van man's on
the channel and we are sponsored by surf
shark enjoy
[Music]
right lawrence
here we are brian right folks we
basically started watching one of blue
vermont videos in the studio the other
day and realized we haven't done a blue
van man video for a long time and we
missed the guy quite well we missed the
guy yeah it says the family sexual for
ages of five and upwards tour full stop
what was this uh sex show um appropriate
for well just ages five and up but i
would assume that this was part of the
rant but i don't know because he does
look annoyed in that thumbnail right
there good morning how are we all on
this day of the morning of what i am
doing i just love his little ford
transit t-shirt oh yeah absolutely yeah
yeah are you not a fan of the ford
transit
that should be as much though shouldn't
it there should be save money it's just
the most dave thing this is a man right
here this well yeah this is a man who's
angry this is an angry frustrated he's a
bit red in the face come on let's see
what he's got to say some people uh are
leaving the comments of this used to be
a good channel uh when you did food
you're really good i'm unsubbing i've
said this before and i will say it again
i'm not bothered if you think i'm gonna
sit there showing calories in my face
making myself fatter giving me a
potential heart attack and stroke or
whatever
it's not funny the idea of dave
obviously uh not being alive upsets me
but like it it's just the way that this
is a food channel as far as i it was a
food channel that was definitely what it
started
i've said this before and i will say it
again i'm not bothered
yeah if you think i'm going to sit there
showing calories in my face making
myself fatter i do giving me a potential
heart attack and stroke or whatever then
you can you're just not bothered about
me personally
dave's not talking about individual
liberty on his own channel but the the
confusion for the fans of the channel is
this is what he sold us on what we need
you to know from now on is if you're
into poker football fighting or
interviews don't be looking at us
because if you think that we're going to
be shoving interviews in our face giving
ourselves potential stress and anxiety
then you're the mugs
some comment dave i feel your
frustration mate this is all part of
their sick agenda
all you're worried about is your own
personal
entertainment there is other youtubers
out there that are more than willing to
go fill their faces every [__] day
and make themselves ill i review life
right i think that's what we do with it
we will just review like just review
life that's so that's such a good
tagline but this is the kind of thing
that makes me [__] angry dave other
things will also do give you a potential
heart second stroke one of them is
stress
one of them is stress dave it is stress
if you're going to lower down on the
calories lower down on the stress as
well it is a big one so i found on there
the other day
that a theater group stages naked family
sex shows to teach children as young as
five [__] five [__] five about sex
a theater group in the united kingdom
which makes the united kingdom he's read
the headline and now he's really
rereading the headline yeah thinks the
best approach teaching kids about sex is
getting naked on a stage in front of
children and their parents
god love him love faith god love him
dave now parents big breasted or
otherwise should not punish their
children for not knowing about sex okay
let's see what he has to say about
people shagging in front of
five-year-olds i think i know so in
theory then
some bloke
and a woman are gonna get naked on a
stage in front of children
and you're gonna take your kid
which could be age five and if you've
got a five-year-old you have a fair
chance that you might have a it might
have a younger brother or sister
um
to a stage to a theater where you see a
man get his [__] out just staying in his
face he knows what he's doing doesn't he
uh
in a glowing preview
by the guardian well that explains the
whole of this then if it's the
this isn't about
uh left wing or being called gammon
people call me gavin just lately i'm
quite i'm the people oh you're a guy
i'm gonna take that as a [__]
compliment
the production company says the show
only discusses the positives of sex and
relationships on purpose well that's
good of them isn't it that's very good
of them to discuss the positives putting
the kid in an awkward situation of
seeing a bloke who's probably in his
[__] 50s with his hanging out looking
like a [__] piece of mcdonald's bacon
i have to look up this show i need to
look up the show to check if what i need
to do is i need to fat check dave to see
if the thing that dave has in his mind
is the same as the actual thing that's
going to appear on the stage family
sex show be careful what you're
searching bro you don't want to [__]
uh it's an anonymous account the family
so cancelled oh i made threats and abuse
at staff probably one of those 7 311
people who watch days later i do like
the idea that some the account goes a
large bald man turned up outside of the
studio today
waving his big fists waving his penis a
funny and silly performance about the
painfully awkward subjects of sex
exploring names and functions boundaries
consent pleasure sex sexuality gender
and relationships dave's thinking of a
sex show like you get in bangkok and
this is not that well they do look a nod
punched on well that's the why you want
to go down to ymca don't you so far i
don't see anyone having sex or the
promotion of sex within this wow this is
the pictures that they've released so
imagine they're all naked you've just
taken the family along i certainly
wouldn't have taken my little ginge uh
to a show just to be absolutely clear
for people who are watching the as his
daughter he doesn't mean his penis to a
show to see some bloke get his [__] out
while some woman gets a [__] frisbee
flips out and they're hanging down by
her [__] knees again dave you are
sort of wondering i'd imagine that any
of these women's breasts are very much
sort of
yeah supper where they used to be
frisbee flips are we letting that are we
letting that go well we used to call uh
women's [__] lips when we were at
school bacon danglers
horrible that the world has never been
so populated he's right about that never
had too many people in it it's a
progressive approach dave again thinks
sex progression means more sex despite
the name the family sex show isn't about
incest did incest once pop into your
mind when you thought that i didn't
really get that far ahead my brain is
sort of just absorbing a lot right now
but if you're gonna get down and start
being naked with your child i'm sorry
what's going on here why is dave cooking
up a scenario where these people are
naked with their children there is one
thing while walking out the bathroom you
forgot your towel or whatever and you
get one out and your kid's accidentally
walking down i have never ever done that
ginge has never ever ever seen me naked
she send me me pants
you see me in my pants oh god but she's
never ever seen my meeting two veg
this is just so good the last time i saw
jin's naked one was when i changed the
nappy when she was
[__] in god knows how old that is the
job of a father to change their child's
nappe right there was no
anything there
i i don't know how we've gotten to
appoint
six minutes
we're only six minutes in and he's now
denying any attraction
there is nothing there all right there's
nothing there
i was doing the job of caring for my kid
this
taking your child to see a grown man
with his [__] out is not protecting and
looking after your child well absolutely
yeah good yeah good i'm also glad that
we uh played up not got a penis because
there was nothing there the artistic
it's called artistic now it's another
way of getting around
getting your [__] out i could do that i
could do i could go into love but stand
outside [__] uh barclays bank and get
me [__] out and say i'm being artistic
it's
making a good point here and i would
also love to see dave go stand outside
to talk to you there's a bit of art
though everybody look at me
[__] artistic i tell you the world's
fault dave you've just made up a
fictional scenario in which you go and
stand outside bargley's bank again not a
real thing not a real thing that's going
on the world's [__] before listing off
its pronouns and describing the physical
appearance for blind viewers for the
visually impaired they've nicked that
[__] off me tell you what if you're
visually impaired you'll have to come
and have a feel then won't you funky
steve were alive today i said yeah steve
i'm going to teach you about sex you
want to touch me cop
just to be clear right if you don't know
the full story about you he had a lovely
uncle god bless him passed away passed
away who was blind and in this fictional
scenario he's got his dead uncle giving
him a hand job because he's trying to
teach him about sex i'll tell you what
i'll take jin's round you can see he can
feel what it's like to [__] what the
[__] i really wonder where dave was
going with that there david joy uh he
had a garage in the village where i
lived and he used to take kids in this
garage and his brain wave was that you
could have sex with children harriet
harmon and some other labour mps there
were you know agreeing with this that
they could have
um sex with kids
i'm sorry i'm so sorry they didn't agree
that that's never been agreed
how would you spell pedo
yeah oh just put that you'll be fine
my work when i was at nccl was
influenced by pie was apologizing for
pedophilia or colluding with pedophilia
that is an unfair inference and it's a
smear there's no attempt to smear
anybody it was the police which reopened
inquiries into this particular pedophile
organization harriet harmon was one of
the loudest mps on the labour benches
calling for full and open transparency
about jimmy savage wow all right
i don't know though because it sounds a
lot like she's basically saying that was
not what she was advocating for he also
put some [__] on her that she has not
addressed there it's terrible certain
mps unfortunately in the past as we
found out we're up to no good he doing
this
believe it or not this theater show this
[__] sex theater show the family sex
show has been funded by the arts council
england
and guess what you know every time you
go and buy a lottery ticket you're
funding this because the [__] lottery
has funded it as well you're funding a
[__] sex show you pedos i love the
fact that he feels like he's uncovering
stuff just an idea blue van man
yes absolutely invetigates i would like
to see a new series where he does a bit
of digging and sees what he can uncover
because he's already educated us on
hartman in a way i think
dave through the dart we had to direct
the dart in slightly the right direction
the lottery has funded this it's
actually just reminded me i would love
to put the lottery on yes i could do
we're getting over this game i'll tell
you tell me about it well i'd just love
to be able to go and see a few more
family sex shows that's me i'll put my
own one on yeah exactly yeah oh he went
to a holiday park right folks we're in
portsmouth well we're in hailing island
for scott and wanda's wedding and
ginger's just taking the dogs for a walk
we've got an aerial we've got an aerial
this is the caravan it's a two berth
well it's two bedrooms the chairs the
cushions are really comfy this man just
refused everything
that's it gingy's bedroom now she's
gonna get her fat ass on there
that's about your daughter i think
you'll find i just did i love how he has
these little combos who are these people
that he makes up
oh ensuite he shocked himself i got
through [__] in there i know they've
been married for a long time but those
doors are very thin those walls are thin
it might as well be paper so having
having an ensuite it leaves nothing to
the imagination yeah i just hope june is
outside she probably has earplugs
because i bet dave's nose so we're just
gonna have a quick chat
about uh the holiday camp first of all
uh the gas wasn't on
uh during the night uh around two
o'clock june decides that she needs a
slash don't talk about women
i love that june gets up and he goes
neither slash and um
couldn't find
the bathroom door apparently i've left
the suitcase in front of the [__]
door okay so it's a couple of days later
now and we can resist just going back
through the blue van man channel i'll
just be honest we just thought it was
really good it turns out he's still
great what i will say is a few days on
it turns out dave is actually happy to
fill his body with some other things
that sounds disgusting so can we watch
it yeah absolutely because i don't
really like kebabs to be honest with you
do you yeah i do actually on a night out
you're going to stuff your face with a
donna kebab when i first started going
out yeah
absolutely yeah i'm all over that [__] i
don't know what's wrong with me but i
never liked that i think you're breaking
a few stereotypes here a few people out
there i reckon would have gone he loves
it
i don't i don't know if i hate them but
it's just hate's a strong word to me
they're disgusting so yes i do hear that
i'm not good
right folks i've not done anything [__]
like this for a while although probably
a lot of you do think that what i am
doing at the moment is [__] whatever am
i right june hello roger uh so what it
is folks as you have seen from the
thumbnail and the thumb title of the
film title that i have not yet taken but
will be this
now i've caught your attention with the
kebab because let's face it most blokes
in this country love akiba what dave
does is he gives you a bit of his
thought process so you know in the last
video dave went sex people clicked that
donna kebabs people click that we're
starting to see dave evolve as a creator
here i'm impressed he's the willingness
of the food world what do you think
kebabs jun
she's auntie kebab
sorry is that the thing that puts you
off that is sort of just meat that's
just rotating on a stick so i used to
work in a butcher shop right okay i kind
of got the um the 4-1-1 on what goes
into a kebab everything you don't want
in an animal that's okay it's that
that's why it tastes so good because
it's all these disgusting little
officers they've been laying on a
[__] butcher shop floor mm-hmm
they've swept it up and thought right
we'll sell a lot of them over the road
uh this is what it looks like that looks
horrible so i've i've placed it on the
flatbed fat bed whatever flatbed like a
flatbed lorry
hold on i'll show you in a second just
for a second doesn't this look like
dave's playing about with his venus it
looks like he's putting a condom on
right so that's what it looks like folks
that was him doing presentation
i thought he was just putting that all
in there and it turns out he was placing
the meat in like even distribution on
the bread just to make it look nice you
can't make this look nice
dave honestly mate what have you done
here this looks [__] horrific
and this
this is the reason why i'm doing more
bloody rants and stuff because this will
kill you not literally kill your butt i
wouldn't put it past it that meat it
could kill you dave is now putting it in
the microwave and we're going to wait
for the microwave to be done most people
would edit this out not dave
i can remember one year when we had an
eclipse one year in the 90s
he's talking about the cliffs in the 90s
do you remember that eclipse yeah i
remember going outside and watching it
that was amazing you guys probably won't
ever see that in your lifetime we both
watched it
this good content
you've won a uh
box of quality streets well done they're
coming at your quality street you know
we're putting out those videos to aliens
and stuff i feel like this should be one
of them they'll think we're not a threat
and they'll move on by they'll be like
[__] earth it's not worth it you've got
a packet of playing cards you gotta go
home tonight looks like sex on a period
that doesn't it right i see what his
taste on
i need a bit of kitchen roll my hands
are all sticking up ah [__] me man this
is the biggest bollocks of a [__]
video ever how long is this video tell
me how long this is
[__] hell it's a kebab we're 14
minutes in and he still hasn't put it in
his [__] mouth he's put one sliver of
it in his mouth and there we have it
folks you see it doesn't look bad no no
yeah he's dressed up you imagine that
the meat isn't made of roadkill
i'm really trying to make that a thing
isn't he he won't have got much meat in
his mouth there will he yeah that was
three slices yeah i'm just hoping the
salad saves it for him
not breathing the roadkill's coming
through now yeah he's looking to feel
around taste the flavor that's coming
it's coming through like gamey
oh
he's done two bites today he absolutely
loves it funny enough
now i've not washed it all up now i've
put all the
all the salad on it the mayonnaise i've
i've placed it out properly
he's absolutely shoving it in his mouth
i love him it doesn't taste that bad
as such
god he's really good he's ramming that
into his neck can we see what else
you've been doing yeah absolutely right
so there's also discussing three lions
which is apparently uh some people are
talking about banning it from the
stadium but they're not really in which
dave wears an england shirt yes i love
it when he gets really patriotic come on
right folks let's discuss is that not
the most manly thing you've ever seen in
your [__] life just took gingy's car
to the garage and as i was coming back
uh my phone went from down the road have
you heard three lines they're not gonna
be allowed to play in the stadium
anymore
i don't know just let me finish this
kebab and i'll let you know i don't want
to do this one on here but
there's a certain newspaper that we do
not like to mention the guardian
england's three lions anthem is facing
the axe
as the country's official world cup song
amid concerns that it offends
other nations i'll just say this we now
retrospectively know that this story is
complete [__] oh that makes it so
that makes it even better it makes it
even better it's yeah another thing
which isn't really a thing yeah but to
dave he can riff on it for 10 minutes
yeah absolutely how long is this video
14 minutes so here's dave uh mourning
the loss of something that isn't
actually lost for the next 14 minutes i
love how how annoyed he is already
[Applause]
i feel like he's just such a typical
englishman who's like country's going to
hell and now yeah exactly yeah gone to
rat [__] this like here we go lions
legend paul gascoignes that song is in
our dna it helps us in 96 uh we still
want one football uh it helps us in 96
and it helped the boys in it'll help the
boys in quater what the [__] is qatar by
the way
the song is viewed as arrogant by other
countries we haven't won anything for 50
years plus what the [__] have we got to
be arrogant about the song is all about
wallowing in 30 years of hurt and pain
and not winning anything how can anyone
say it's arrogant i've just said that
i've just i've not read this i've just
said that i've not read the article i've
said that but i've said it
i agree with the paper that i hate
who said it first though yeah
the people that i read it after or me
who said it before i read it and apart
from that in one way
what is wrong with being arrogant
manchester united sir alex ferguson made
his teams arrogant they thought they
were going to win everything and pretty
much [__] dead what is wrong with
being arrogant the germans are arrogant
here comes some generalizations about
other nations the germans are arrogant
the italians are in arrogant they ain't
going to be playing a song are they
they're gonna be playing [__]
nesendore or whatever it's called
[Music]
true yeah what is wrong with being
arrogant arrogant's a a good thing in a
tournament like this you're going to go
out there and you're going to feel i'm
invincible
that's what you want was that one of the
lines
dave's just making up songs now you want
to be felt like you people are [__]
scared of you intimidated you you
crossed that line you're going into some
kind of war and now people are looking
about the war ukraine and russia
totally different [__] subjects
they're on about bringing in sweet
caroline by neil [__] diamond god
this man gets so stressed doesn't he a
song about an eleven year old girl with
it would they what's sweet caroline
about sort of hero song was it
was a girlish caroline kennedy who was
12. and this is a picture of her oh
little girl and a horse it was sort of
an auto the young daughter of john f
kennedy but diamond revealed
it was
love song for then wife the most
challenging part of the song was finding
the right name to dedicate the simple
love song to at the time he was married
to martial murphy and had promised her a
song it was a love song to my wife
marsha was uncle sweet caroline you seem
to have mispronounced your wife's name
there
look at the lyrics of this [__] because
i've never actually thought about what
you're saying yeah yeah yeah what are we
singing about whether that's wrong and
touching hands reaching out touching
touching me
sweet caroline good times never seem so
good
i've been inclined and is this a ploy
again to get people riled up because he
certainly wrote me up as he says nine
and a half minutes into his youtube runs
about this topic i've been riled up here
i've known june you have done
yeah is this a ploy is this a game
because
people seem to think that i'm wearing a
tin app but the problem is in the last
two years i just don't [__] believe
anything i really hear now on the news
or the media i want to say though i do
agree with dave
okay so what i will say is what i like
about dave is some people might land on
that video of dave and go this [__]
old gammon just having to go at people
and doing things nine minutes in he's
gone through the anger he's gone through
and worked it through in his mind and
then he's gone hold on a minute have i
been sucked in so dave's smarter than
your average bear i like his rants and
that's what i wanna i wanna see more of
bbc ignore henry viii oh my god i've
gotta watch that now
no right folks that's what it were i
like that shirt by the way what it says
on the front david front of dave's shirt
is it's no longer our job
i've seen on the internet
that the bbc are doing a new series uh
an eight-part series called art that
made us um and it's going to explore
turbulent periods of british history
through the lens of art literature music
design but
henry viii
is not going to be included in this how
the [__]
can you have the
4 000 year history of britain and not
have
one of the most
controversial figures of our british
history not in it if they ever do like a
recreation of henry viii i think dave
would make a great henry dave should
play henry yeah yeah absolutely that is
basically what he did and he did that
there to the pope he says i'm not having
it i'm not having you telling me what i
can do what i can't do it was the
original brexit of britain telling
europe to [__] off i see where dave's
coming from in many ways dave's actually
bang on there because it was led by one
man wanting something just so he could
shag around a bit more dave again
enlightening us that's generous but i
see where you're going with it what was
happening is that the catholic church
was ruling europe so while the pope's
messing around with whoever he wants to
mess around with you have to send
somebody on an horse henry would say can
i divorce this woman and then he'd say
no you can't because of whatever and
then he said well [__] you then cocker
am i the only person who is detecting a
slight tinge of admiration for henry of
the year i'm feeling his enjoyment at
henry theater doing that to the system
yeah i think there's a little bit of him
that take and good on him the turner
prize winning artist to discuss a
painting of henry viii called filled
with cloth filled of cloth of gold
filled of the cloth of gold sorry
i'll edit this bit out
you can cut that bit i'll edit this out
edit out let me just get that back up so
i can carry on reading it no for [__]
sake
where is it
he's left all this in where is that on
her
right
i'll edit this bit out
yeah so um he edited the he edited the
bit
where he said after us but he forgot
before that the best thing is he did it
they're always trying to change history
they're always trying to oh we can't put
that in because we might defend somebody
and it was a bit of a naughty time then
it's all bollocks on about taking david
livingston's bloody statue down in
glasgow now because he might have had
links with slavery back in the 1800s
every [__] had links with uh slavery
you went over you bought they bought
some [__] cotton bat they made some
wall you wear a jumper it's made a
[__] wall that's been picked by a
slave you can't [__] help it another
thing i should be picking up on here is
the slavery thing but cotton is cotton
and wool is uh from the sheep the other
stuff i'm gonna skirt over because we
just don't have time for that in this
video i [__] fed up with it all these
crap that you can't bloody that just
happened years ago and that people are
just gonna ignore it i tell you what why
don't we just ignore the fact that
england won the world cup in 1966
because there was no black players i'm
really in shock at this let's forget
bobby moore bobby moore and the charlton
brothers yes and the jeff hearst let's
let's forget that nobody's no one's
making these accusations and no one's at
any point saying that the england team
wasn't inclusive enough a time where
dave sort of has an argument with
himself let's forget that because there
was no blacks in the team i'm not sure
this is funny anymore he's created
people that aren't saying things and
he's then gotten quite angry with these
people no one at any point has said
write
out of history
because black people hadn't played
football with him it's just pathetic
it's just [__] you cannot change what
happened in the past that's about that
that's the broad point he's trying to
make in this fictional scenario which
isn't happening yes about the 66 world
cup being cancelled right which it isn't
and no one is trying to cancel those
people definitely you cannot do it and
the bbc are helping this every [__]
time i'm worried about his blood
pressure me too [__] fed up with yeah
what happened then was bad it was a
complete different [__] time it's
like you you look at stuff now right
you look at stuff time in time now
that's happened now today in 50 years
and people say oh that was terrible why
wouldn't we do something about it
probably in this video that is a very
good point dave's making an intellectual
point here about how everything in the
context of its time has its own validity
and i can understand that
why don't you do something about the
[__] slave sweatshops in leicester
and all other places but no you turn a
[__] blind eye to that one i very
much agree i didn't know there were
slavery workshops well i i think what he
means is when you pay people such as a
small amount of money right okay so
trapping people in a situation they want
to be do we move on now i think so um i
want to congratulate matt leticia a
great career yeah
are you familiar with some of matt
leticia's recent tweets absolutely
absolutely very familiar with matt
tessier's recent tin hattery i'm
actually stepping up
and saying what he thinks about things
that are happening in the world it's
about ukraine i personally right don't
trust our media on anything at the
moment in time valid point well not on
anything but so not valid points sorry
there's a lot
there i think we're being manipulated
matt has left southampton he was the
ambassador
did matt loses ambassadorship over this
is this the hill to die on matt matt
said on another tweet on wednesday
morning to make this very clear it does
not advocate war in any shape or form i
didn't advocate war how do you get to a
point where you need a tweet oh i don't
advocate war we used to watch matt
leticia on soccer they see that soccer
saturday see there's another thing isn't
it we're now calling it soccer it's not
[__] soccer it's football because the
americans want us to say soccer i think
the reason it happened is it was it was
alliteration and actually soccer is a
word that comes from us football fat
today doesn't work does it right it's
[__] football it'll always be
football it's always been football so
could we can't start calling it football
saturday it's just another thing where
the media and everything just kind of
just tap into your head and say i'm
literally so shocked that we're three
minutes in and we've gone from matt
leticia denying a war to be inside to
know we need to call soccer football
everyone in this country already does
it's just the name of the tv show soccer
get out and everybody get saying soccer
dave's sending out a message through his
own break
that's the last video our government has
been lying to us for [__] years and
years and years all you've got to do is
just go back to iraq with the weapons of
nasty stuff mass destruction mass
disturbance
i was there sorry dave was in iraq i was
there
i seen them i was there thinking oh
[__] out what they're gonna do if the
[__] saddam just decides to send just
one [__] weapon over to us what
happens if he decides to [__] bomb
love bro
i just got this instant like team
america style sketchum ahead of them
[Music]
they [__] scare you and that is what
their [__] job is but because now
people are
starting to [__] question what they
do and this is why i do these videos i
don't care about [__]
views of my [__] food and stuff i've
gone beyond that i've broken the
stratosphere of food i am now political
van man [__] eating food for a living
and getting bigger and [__] bigger as
some kind of entertaining [__] sea
lion
he really reminds me of me i really love
him what am i a sea lion to you i want
people to watch my videos now i want
people to start questioning what the
[__] is going on in this contract
because the government and the [__]
media cover everything up and they tell
you they drill you they [__] try to
make you believe what they want you to
believe jimmy savile
jimmy [__] savile i knew the pedos
were coming that this was coming at some
point here we go guys ready we're about
to go on a roller coaster from a man who
reads the ingredients of donna kabab
package
have you watched it have you watched it
on netflix you watched it yeah i have
now and it's still being covered up
today it's still being covered up for
what that dirty [__] nonce bastard
did and this is what's happening now do
you know what i think we got a day of
others moment there there was some ups
and downs along the way absolutely we've
been on such a journey from again a man
who reads the ingredients of a donaka
bad packet and trusts that but doesn't
trust the media that was blue van man if
you've got any more blue van man videos
you'd love us to watch or there's
anything else that you think in
particular we should react to send it to
us tweet it or whatever and we'll we
will see it we're on social media on
social media yeah all of them obviously
we love dave do show them some love
hundred and forty seven thousand
subscribers on the blue vermont channel
and we're looking with him we do not
endorse a single thing he says
absolutely but we are laughing with him
see you soon and uh dave uh
we love you yeah happy day
sorry about that
yeah question everything
question everything questions